something that people back away from
when they hear the phrase Christian
nationalism they'll say well goodness
what does that mean for Jews what does
that mean for Muslims what does that
mean for regular old agnostics and
atheists and my answer to that is it
means what it has always meant which is
the greatest country on Earth that
people of all of those backgrounds seek
to flock to I'm making an historical
observation that the United States
political order has been Christian
nationalism during those centuries of
Christian nationalism plenty of Jews
have flocked here plenty of of Muslims
have flocked here and plenty of atheists
and agnostics as well because the the
idea of a Christian Nation is not to say
that we give a preference or a special
privilege to one religious group over
another religious group it's to say this
is how we view the world and we're going
to treat people with certain Privileges
and rights and dignity and all the rest
of it based on our our Christian view so
in practice Jews Muslims atheists
agnostics will flourish much better
under a Christian Nation